this is Stuffle it's a classic Italian
dessert served at the holidays and I've
made mine a little extra festive with
some confetti cake crumbles right on top
if you've never made truffle it's
basically little balls of dough made
with orange and lemon zest that are
fried in oil and then coated with a
honey orange sauce making them really
sticky and sweet and delicious once
they're made you pile them into this
reath shape and it's always a little
nerve-wracking removing the cup from the
middle of the cake because you just
really hope it doesn't all fall apart
it's traditionally topped with sprinkles
but these confetti cake crumbles are
really fun and easy to make and they
make the whole dish just perfect Cor